an eyelid off Sweden's west coast just
north of gothenburg the landscape is
dominated by granite sculpted by
retreating Ice Age glaciers the little
port of share Ham has a population of
just over 3,000 which doubles in summer
when the cottage owners and foreign
tourists arrive fish has always played a
leading part in the region's cuisine
herring cod and place are among the
species caught in these waters literally
on the water is the restaurant called
button meaning simply water it does its
best business during lunch time and ash
serena has run button since 2006 I
wanted to have it quite clean because I
want the people to look at the plate and
also we have a nice view here so I don't
want have it not anything here
disturbing because it's that way you
should look at that way and maybe in two
beautiful eyes
for three and a half years panic Vicki
Gillian has been buttons head chef he
concentrates on fish dishes only logical
given the vast supply right outside the
door he was born in the area and wants
to continue to build on the traditions
of Western Swedish cuisine here now
Cloris mocha latte I try to emphasize
the original taste of the ingredients
while main ingredient is always the
focus so my dishes are always quite
simple I generally use one main
ingredient with three or four side
dishes they no more complicated than
that for me accomplish a little hen like
Vicki Greene buys the fish for the stew
he'll be preparing for euromax fresh off
the boat right near the restaurant today
it's Cod and Ling a relative of the card
he also needs muscles and prawns on the
Swedish coast the kind of fish on the
menu depends on the season it's obvious
sealed a lot of herring is pickled here
the peak season for it is around the
Midsummer Festival and Christmas and
Easter in summer we fry a lot of
mackerel it's served with potatoes very
simple and a good source source term for
our stew hemmlich Vicki Greene has
prepared a fish broth of crayfish shells
and vegetables thickened with butter and
cream if you don't have the time to cook
your own fish broth you can buy a
ready-made broth you just have to get
the right concentration for this dish of
course it's best to make your own broth
ignore hen like Vicki Greene only uses
fresh seasonal
cutting them in large pieces for the
stew he fillets the fish and cut it into
bite-sized morsels and cooks them in
white wine and water
while the fish simmers hen like Vicki
Greene fries the prawn halves with
garlic he drains the sauteed vegetables
and arrange them on a bed of shrimp he
adds the cooked mussels arrangers the
cooked fish on the plates and tops it
off with a prawn house finally he pours
the fish broth over each serving and
garnishes them with Dylan watercress the
result is a genuine Western swedish fish
stew it's best when enjoyed with a glass
of dry white wine
you